kitami today's bar chart has Gold Fever
faded now from November the fifth last
year the green circle right there this
is a two-year chart by the way 2030 into
2015 from the member the fifth last year
through January the 22nd this year you
can see there was a steady progression
upwards that's the red circle gold did
rise by fourteen percent since that day
in January since the red circle goal has
fallen back it's dropped by almost eight
percent it's fallen for four consecutive
weeks the longest losing run since sep
tember the 20th 2013 this of course
comes after the precious metal slit by
one point seven percent in 2014 dropping
for a second year for the first time
since 2000 in 2013 by the way gold fell
by twenty eight percent its biggest
slump since 1981 our gold has been
falling even as grease battles with its
creditors we've got the strengthening
dollar record valuations for global
equities diminishing it appeal as a
store of wealth this month's losses in
exchange-traded products backed by gold
have reached almost four billion dollars
the net long position in gold tumbled
eighteen percent in the week ended
februari the 17th that's the third
straight drop and the longest streak
since november according to CFTC data
even john paulson the billionaire hedge
fund manager he's showing less
enthusiasm for the metal these days he
kept his stake in the world's biggest
ETP backed by boolean unchanged for a
sixth straight quarter as of the end of
2014 water analysts saying they don't
see big moves in the price of gold this
year the median price forecast for gold
at the end of 2013 from the 31 analyst
we've surveyed here at Bloomberg is 1231
dollars that's roughly thirty dollars
ahead of today's price asset manager
incremental is the most bullish with a
forecast of $1,500 followed by L BBW
with a prediction of 1400 sawston
general is the most bearish
with a forecast of nine hundred and
fifty dollars BNP Paribas has a forecast
of 960 dollars what is it about French
banks being bearish on the price of gold
has Gold Fever faded